there was an awkward photo challenge  everyone knows about this to raise money  for hurricane relief and everyone was  supposed to send in an awkward picture  of their youth and you sent in I think  you I think you broke the rules I think  you sent in the coolest picture of a kid  I have seen in my life check this out  ladies and gentlemen this is the photo  how is that how is the head and you look  like Elvis and then it's what I got too  much hair and I'm fat as a tick awkward  you know yeah I took the awkward photo  seriously this is the one I sent in and  you can see them side by side you can  see that you're by far I could have sent  in a picture with me and my Hough along  Cassidy outfit rotting a horse yeah or  sitting on a horse yeah I think you did  the right that's a very cool photo  nothing to be ashamed about it against  that car  you